With a tidal wave of hype, director Rian Johnson
and the team at Lucasfilm opened the flood
gates when they revealed that the 8th entry
in the Star Wars episodic films would be called
“the last jedi”.
But just who is the last jedi?
The straight forward, to the point title is
actually one of the more vague titles the
space opera has had, allowing for plenty of
speculation to go around.
Here are Screenrant’s 5 crazy star wars
theories about “the last jedi”.
Have a suggestion of your own?
Let us know in the comments and give us a
like if you were blown away by some of these
theories!
Obvious spoilers for The force awakens!
Luke and Kylo Ren
Betcha didn’t see that one coming.
But it’s true; the plural form of “jedi”
is still “jedi”, thus making it totally
possible that the title can be about two or
more different beings.
With its ominous red color pallet, “the
last jedi” may very well deal heavily on
one of the last jedi luke himself trained,
that being the fallen jedi padawan Ben Solo,
also known as Kylo Ren.
Dealing with the reality of murdering his
own father may have taken his toll on the
master of the knights of ren and adam driver
has stated that the film will further explore
the characters humanity.
Since Luke and Kylo are technically the last
two alive that have formal jedi training and
are family, having the film deal heavily with
these two characters seems more than likely.
Just Luke
The obvious choice would be that this film
will be focused heavily on Luke Skywalker.
Referred to as “the last jedi” on multiple
occasions, including from master yoda himself
stating “when gone I am, the last of the
jedi you will be” and from supreme leader
snoke himself when he says “he droid will
soon be delivered to the Resistance, leading
them to the last Jedi.
If Skywalker returns, the new Jedi will rise”.
Luke is finally referred to as the last jedi
in the opening crawl of the force awakens.
Being almost absent from the force awakens
yet having the plot be so focused on the missing
jedi, we should not be surprised if the film
deals heavily with Luke’s demons and motivations
in a world where his own nephew has massacred
his jedi academy, bringing to ruins the dying
with of yoda.
Luke and Rey
Kylo ren said it himself; she is strong with
the force.
And while that may be so, Rey still has no
formal jedi training (or sith training while
we’re being specific).
Despite his failure, Luke may find it in himself
to once again pick up his saber and teach
what he has leaned, passing it down to another.
Rey just so happens to have the lightsaber
that belonged to his father, which basically
demands instant training.
The film may explore their relationship and
the training that they will possibly undertake,
thus entering rey into the formal order of
jedi (population, 2).
The two of them would thus make the last two
jedi alive and the beginning of the next rebirth
to counteract snoke and the first order.
The force is calling to her after all.
Just Rey
What if the title is being extra literal?
What if luke decides to train rey different
than all the rest that have come before her;
changing the rules up and the foundations
of the jedi academy?
Would she still be a jedi?
Unlikely, as she would become something else
altogether, a new identity with a new name,
thus rending luke the last of his kind.
This would be further personified if luke
should meet his demise in episode 8 or episode
9.
Someone from the past or an outside agent
The galaxy is a vast place, filled with plenty
of people.
Odds are, there are some force users out there.
What if the last jedi pertains to someone
we haven’t met before?
Maybe there is another survivor from the academy
or someone who is tied to rey’s family that
we haven’t met before.
Shockingly enough, the possibility of supreme
leader snoke being a jedi isn’t impossible
either.
More interesting though is taking the title
literally: the last jedi.
Who were the last jedi?
Well the last to die would be yoda, obi wan
Kenobi and Anakin skywalker.
If rey turns out to be a Kenobi or skywalker,
having them appear as force ghosts would play
into the title and be a welcome connection
to the prequel era films.
The last jedi falls nicely into Anakin’s
redemption as well and during the unveiling
of the title, Lucasfilm stated that “the
last jedi” would be the next chapter of
the skywalker saga”.
So there you have it!
Those are our crazy theories as to who the
last jedi could be.
Who do you think it could be?
Is it one person?
Two?
What are your theories?
Let us know in the comment section below and
don’t forget to subscribe to our channel
where you can find more videos like this one
every day.
May the force be with you.